le gouvernement fédéral tient absolument
installer un péage sur le nouveau pont
champlain une expérience semblable en
banlieue de vancouver a aussi été tenté
un pont à péage ouvert il ya à peine
deux ans est désertée en ce moment parce
que les prix sont trop élevés
alors les automobilistes pour éviter de
payer se tourner vers un vieux banc qui
lui est gratuit
frédéric arnold une heure de pointe dès
15 heures l'avenue royale de new
westminster en banlieue de vancouver
déborde
une anomalie qui se répète chaque jour
depuis des mois catalina trinidad qui
habite ici depuis 16 ans n'en peut plus
de cette congestion qui génère pollution
et bruit matin et soir ils se dirigent
tous vers le pont pas tout l'eau parce
qu'il est gratuit
la cause de tous les maux le voici une
merveille construite au coût de plus de
3 milliards de dollars inauguré en
grande pompe par la ministre de l'époque
en 2012 le pont portman relie les
municipalités de l'anglais serait
cockpit l'âme à l'autoroute 1 qui mène à
vancouver par passage il en coûtait dès
son ouverture de 1 dollar 50 à 4 dollars
et demi selon le type de véhicule
en guise de prix d'introduction un prix
doublé depuis janvier 2013
résultat le trafic quotidien de 100
mille utilisateurs a chuté de plus de
6000 véhicules celui du pont pas tout
lui a augmenté de 10 à 16%
catalina se désole des automobilistes et
camionneurs qui fuit le pont à péage
nous démentons détruits
c'est la toile bon étant l'une des
conséquences directes de la déviation de
la circulation automobile du pont à
péage vers le pont gratuit c'est une
augmentation de 32% depuis un an du
nombre d'accidents graves sur le pont
gratuit la solution un nouveau pont pas
tout l'eau à plus de 800 millions de
dollars
et devinez quoi on y installerait un
péage ne peut pas tout lui appartient à
translink l'agencé métropolitaine de
transport de la région
la solution du péage est l'une des
avenues pourtant l'expérience de lagence
avec les ponts à péage n'est pas très
concluant jusqu'ici l' agence possède
aussi le pont golden ears c'est le seul
autre pont payant de la province il
accusera un déficit de 35 à 45 millions
de dollars dans les prochaines années
pendant ce temps la corporation qui gère
le pont portman revoit aussi à la baisse
ses prévisions de revenus de 20%
mais pour le ministre provincial des
transports pas question de baisser le
prix du péage pour désengorger pas tout
l'eau et pour ré appâter le trafic vers
portman bref les péages sont là pour
rester et peut-être même pour cet enfant
mais à quel prix ici frédéric arnould
radio-canada et westminster